people will like you that's what matters
we're a mere it didn't matter people's
approvals number one in my book all-time
movies Greg is here and Kyle Kyle is
here all-time movies
these guys are Brits are all these guys
and they live into all time no movies
all stavros Easter eggs original series
it's if you're a star Wars fan you've
come to the right channel yeah my house
a Star Wars fan I have seen all four
Star Wars movies because the little
Easter eggs in their movies it's awesome
yes initially they're there just for the
crew members satisfaction but these days
they're there for the fans too so let's
go back to when mad movie fandom really
started and go through all the Star Wars
original trilogy Easter eggs good at
least all the ones I could find a new
hope is that it lights on Easter eggs
but it does have lots of treats for
eagle-eyed viewers for instance when the
Tusken Raiders are looking at the sands
feeder there were some carvings on the
rock behind them well these might be
ancient carvings but actually they're
more likely to be marks made by the film
crew during setup to note where the
actors and property on-screen picture is
zipping on to the cantina scene and you
can see that the distillery parts were
recycled in Episode four was bounty
hunter idat eights head and over here
you can also see this alien is an extra
in a national uniform he has over in
this shot you can see him again with
another bloke than an astronaut outfit
you can see the costume department just
covered the United States flag on his
arm you can see a veritable Amy oh yeah
his name is actually maxiblack he had a
couple of close-ups in the original 1977
version of the film but George Lucas cut
him out to the special edition and
replaced him with Kent wall and elephant
he's an interesting observation for you
this is the over time a lightsaber
doesn't immediately cauterize a limb
that dominates in the series that always
punch also one of the few times we see
in the trilogy Luke has have been
learned on his face after the Whomper
attack and the walkers are joined some
rarely and then leaking a little red
stuff himself
zeb semester also people dying in the
Battle of Hoth I don't think there's any
blood in Return of the Jedi
also appearing for one time only is a
pair of gold fitted dice in the
Millennium Falcon they just disappeared
for the rest of the film one of the
series still on the Millennium Falcon
and in the training droid seeing Luke's
or Anakin's lightsaber is white for a
couple of shots in 1977 it was widely
entire scene but George went back and
fixed it for the 2011 blu-rays except
not in every shot at least is not green
like in the 2004 DVDs fast forward to
the Death Star and Luke's a story is
being transferred from cellblock 1-1 3-8
a reference to George Lucas's first film
a 9 th X Y and create Oh call me the
reference to it in this scene on the
screen behind CPP Oh in r2d2 you can
barely make it out but it's there then
we have this famous moment where this
stormtrooper opens his head on the door
George Lucas even added in a sound
effect for it and of course we have
found serene
sound designer ben burtt named after a
character called wolf who screams it in
1950s the charge it for the river that
is actually the voice of actor ship
Wooley from the film distant drums from
1951 ah now the Empire Strikes Back has
a blink in your miss it can go from
Ralph for a from Macquarie the man who
defined the entire look of Star Wars
core the very least he designed to Becca
r2d2 cqp Oh Dolph way there aren't most
of the vehicles that's why he's holding
the sketchpad nice that's really cool
there's also a cameo from Jeremy Bulloch
who plays Boba Fett you can hear his
voice any more additions who the one
using there is a human shield because
neither and that did rebel officer major
derp they played by John Ratzenberger
his voice is dubbed in this film I
easily Becca how is the voice of no ears
1 1 3 reference I hope you get to home
screens
in the chinku the asteroid field all the
asteroids in the background are two toes
and this asteroid is sculpted around a
tennis shoe but in the same sequence if
the pause and play through the
typewriter crash frame by frame you can
see the pilot fly out in flames and pour
that's amazing cool yeah that extra is
carrying an ice cream maker except his
name is Robert Wood not the actor's name
the character's name is willow hood he's
got a backstory and everything the ice
cream maker is supposed to be a
computer's memory cord with details of
his contacts in the rubber the lights
Thanks you even get an actually picker
or shout out that's a nice and this is
just me or is that Mickey Mouse in
Return of the Jedi there's a great can
go from sound designer Ben Burtt yes and
that sound he makes has actually him
doomed a great impression of Wilhelm
scream sound I wouldn't mind being
killed by cancer
what's great speaking of the bull on
screen there are a few in this film yeah
but you do listen really carefully for
this one at the end from the storybook
aha there is a reference to 1-1 3-8 in
Episode six but you can't see it
it's written on the side of layers of
brooch helmet but this is the only shot
like a coin where you can see that side
of a helmet and frankly the light isn't
good enough to actually make it out
but you can see that the a wing that
crunches into the set at the superstar
destroys bridge is really a car chassis
and while there are platforms deliberate
easter eggs you can totally see Harrison
Ford copping a feel
oh yeah yeah sharing this knowledge with
you for science so those are all the
Star Wars original trilogy Easter eggs I
could find which is your favorite please
tell me in the comments and stay tuned
to this channel for more movies Easter
egg deliciousness but if you can't wait
then click right there but Livi's
countdown of every that's right every
toy story Easter egg showing insane
making it dude well done guys you guys
did a great job there that was funny
I'd like that the the guy from cheers
and toy story was in it I remember when
someone pointed out to me I was like
what you don't expect that I don't know
Star Wars seems that if distant from
certain things that astronaut a stern
ought I knew I saw that the first time I
saw him like they just got lazy
apparently I'm like gotta fill it with
something yeah it does feel very much
like retro sci-fi old-school that's when
it feels like a dated kind of effect
yeah though it's kind of a cool thing
it's like maybe that's them from our
there our earth you know maybe there's a
little story we could do towards those
specific human being they'd have to
travel way far back in time because this
takes place a long time ago in a galaxy
far far away it depends how time is
perceived through space travel what Star
Trek fans little wolf thing with these
glowing red eyes I feel so bad for the
costume designer who like built them
only for Lulu Lucia so like how did
Lucas become the most hated guy of all
this no we're the guy who Satan is the
grenade why would he do that though it's
such a small thing - this guy clearly
went out of his way
creep this costing this effect and it
looked really cool as a practical
costume and then he cuts it out my
screen time that effect I know for that
like and that's that's CG right yeah
full CG I heard actually that he changed
and this could be complete baloney but I
heard that he changed and created the
special edition why all versions of it
are not like the original anymore
because of there's some kind of legal
documents his wife or ex-wife had or
someone had and in order for him to keep
all of the the money associated with the
franchise he had to change it enough
that it was technically a different set
of films that could be complete BS but
that's what I heard that that he
actually that's why they originally did
the special editions I just think George
Lucas is a money man and he thought we
could PG this up would get more money
that makes perfect sense as well yeah
like ridiculous conspiracy it's an army
any cut off in in it in the first I was
like wait yeah why was there blood it
should have just been like singed it's a
really disturbing shot actually mm-hmm
it's like actually like a moment
excluding when Luke's tied up in the
beginning of Empire Strikes Back
yeah and that creature is macking on the
human this to me is like one of the few
moments in Star Wars where I actually
like kind of found myself cringing a
little oh yeah because there is
something like weirdly disturbing about
that because it looks like an animal's
arms been cut off but they know that
when you look at it that way it looks
like an animal's arms being sliced off
by hope you won't Cano be so sad
I like how they pointed out all the
blood from the original from the whole
trilogy it's true there's really not
much Blair isn't know and when it's
there it's kind of just it's kind of
like it's noticeable you know yeah like
it stands out which people tell bleed in
Star Wars I would love like a really
bloody story mess room so sweet oh yeah
this lightsabers built differently too
not only is it like white or slightly
mint colored but it's like more of a
line like if you look at it
yeah it's more of a like a sword shape I
wish I wish he didn't make it like I
wouldn't have mine like that was the one
thing that in the whole trilogy of all
is like weird touch-ups the one thing I
really do I thought he could have done
was like yeah fix the light saver a
little bit yeah a little bit little
touch like smooth it out a little bit
yeah not too distracting cuz I'm like
it's already like CGI oh yeah yeah just
touch it up to change the color to green
was like the come on man that's it the
for Return of the Jedi I didn't see
Lucas's first film thx 1-1 3-8
was over thx comes from yes that's cool
isn't that cool I like those references
I got out of the matrix that's like 101
a lot of that throughout their films and
I didn't realise Star Wars had 1-1 3-8
yeah and I don't remember I thought that
thx was an acronym or something for
something I don't know if that's
actually a thing either I think he just
chose letters and chose tempers and yeah
oh I love the the Alva what's it called
the Wilhelm the sound effect very good
god McQuarrie the guy who designed all
the Star Wars awesome characters that's
really cool they gave him a cameo I
think that's really great yeah including
Darth Vader and like some of the ships
too yeah it's so cool when that when the
crew people like the a lot of times
these crew members are really all about
being all the crew and doing their job
you know yeah I have to be so it's cool
when they give them a little shout out
in front of the camera like that those
are my favorite kind of Easter eggs
actually that's what that is yeah it's
nice nice that's really cool that that
one shot where that guy's flying out of
the air oh yeah that's cool I never
noticed that never notice that yeah no I
love that kind of stuff because most
people just like to take the cheap easy
way route I love that attention to
detail because it's not necessary but
sometimes when you throw in those little
details the audience may not know on the
surface they happened but it does make
for a more powerful effect yeah
subliminally at least it's cool when
they have those like especially for
people like us who like to see these
kind of videos or you like slow down to
film let's check out more detail
yeah this is little extra attention to
details it's like a lot of times people
might not include that cousin [ __ ]
knows this guy anyway yeah but its
commitment to the art yeah cool I like
that I didn't know that Han copped a
feel I did it was so obvious right oh
yeah there's so unnecessary we're gonna
move that way to you totally copped a
feel Oh
first she stayed with his hand on her
shoulder and then he grabs her The
Adventures of Indiana bones right yes we
just played a witness to that that was
great
Air Force one that one I got more of
these what are some what she did she
went if you look at the shot she
actually looks like she's enjoying it I
think she was I'm sure they had sex well
all-time movies good job again I'm proud
of you guys you guys worked your asses
off you put almost as much work into
that video as I do from like most of my
videos so decent work pedaling back
there if you did this channel this
hard-working much more like edited out
channel not like these alts I movie is
good
subscribe to the real rejects Kyle he
tweets apparently any periscope he's
apparently a periscope II and I just saw
him do a scene in acting class from high
fidelity
he played John Cusack that's me sure I
never thought I'd say this but John
Cusack was miscast I should have been